and so I was here 16 years ago but it's
always interesting revisiting after so
much time away whether that be a human
or a place and you've changed it's
changed you go back to some memories
things look different I gotta say a more
sober this time it was out partying in
one of these streets with this guy fly
this Russian guy and it was crazy we are
well I met him at this bar met him at
this bar in this in the town he said you
want to go you want to go to the
nightclub drink with me and I said sure
so I met him that night and we walked up
these streets I'm very close to that
place and there was this thumping of the
the loud Russian pop and we went through
a long hallway up a flight of stairs
the massive dancefloor glitter ball with
lights going in about 25 people on the
dance floor dancing so Vlad and I sat
down got our beers start drinking and
not long after a beer bottle comes
flying in flying in smash on the
dancefloor and so let's go over here
this looks cool
smash on the dance floor and so everyone
stops dancing and they look at us but
then they resume they start dancing
again about five minutes later another
bottle comes in smash and this time
everyone sort of stops looks at me and
comes forward like like a crescent moon
and I didn't know what was gonna happen
and this little girl step forward and
she's like you throwing
beer bottles at us as always you know
drinking my beer so it was impossible
for me to throw it firstly I wouldn't do
that secondly I had a beer in my hand
and well not long after drost for today
hello right after she steps up stocky
girl comes up to about here on me comes
up and just boom hits me right in the
cheekbone on the ground now all these
big guys these stocky locals grab the
chairs have these big wooden chairs and
so I'm seeing the outcome not looking so
good for flight and I and I make a
beeline a run a run for the stairs I go
around one side of the table she goes
around the other and gets me before the
stairs with a flying karate kick no joke
seriously like flying kick I block it
and for one second I actually laugh it's
funny because this little girl is
kicking the out of me but then it's
not so funny because all our friends are
following and ready ready to finish the
job and so at this point in time
Vlad takes a bullet beer bottle and just
boom
smashes over a guy's head and I see the
blood is flowing down and
at this time the adrenaline just is like
through my veins and so there's a to
tear there's steps and there's like to
tears down the flight of stairs and it's
just one big boom one big leap and jump
half a flight of stairs that jumped
landed compressed did it again got to
the bottom ok now this building filled
up with people and there are a couple
other like little dance parties
downstairs in different rooms in a long
hallway and I'm running by people so
they're all hanging out like this
drinking their drinks and I'm running by
and I'm knocking everyone's beer out of
hands and stepping on their feet I'm
running into them and so I get out to
the street and the whole bar thinks
thinks I did something terrible and so
get out to the street it's like a roar
behind me and I look out in the street
and it's dark fully dark and in
Kyrgyzstan I haven't seen it this time
but 16 years ago people were stealing
the manhole covers smelting the metal
and making money out of us so though the
street was like Swiss cheese or out
there all these holes in the chin the in
the street so I put on the seventh grade
soccer sprint full-on sprint and now I'm
worried about becoming castrated more
than anything else as a foot goes down
one of these holes in the dark dark
night of Caracol kyrgyzstan and so I
outran everyone I wasn't drunk I think I
was the only one not drunk in vlad vlad
thought it was Stalingrad
so I had wanted to fight like it was
Stalingrad and you know go down with
some pride to the bitter end that was
the last I saw up lad you can hear
here closely you might even hear Vlad
still going
his last gasps of air his last fist of
flying so that's my story how is beat up
by a girl here in catechol and so I woke
up the next day with a big shiner like a
massive massive bump on my face and well
everyone thought it was funny
everyone got a kick out of that story I
thought it was hilarious but don't let
me put you off don't let me put you off
of Caracol this is really quite a
magical place I mean it's it's it's
quite rough around the edges for sure
and the economy looks to be pretty beat
up but there's also as you've seen these
cool people these mountains this lake
there's a certain rawness to the place
like a definitely a power up here the
skies the clouds the air and then you
see stuff like this looks like well an
old ferris wheel I'm moving anymore here
we got a go-kart track so that's my
story how I got beer it beat up in
Kyrgyzstan by a girl